[拍手]
じゃあから止めていく事業こと申します今日どうぞよろしくお願い致します
経た今日は私は社会を彫刻し続けるちょっと濃く者を噛みそうなタイプではあるんです
けれども
えっと私の活動社会をトークをするという活動について少し話させて頂きたいと思い
ます
でこの言葉これ私なりに提供したものなので今日は皆さん
社会を彫刻するっていうことをなんとなく頭の中で押さえながら自分だったら当社から
象谷するかについて少し入ってください
よさせていただきます
社会に対する自分の中のさまざまな問題意識に向き合いながら自らの創造性や創造力を
用いて私生活や仕事にあるから家事を作り続け行動する
私はこういうこと自体を社会勝負だと考えながら
周年一発作りなど教育特定ぱなど
関わっています
でも少しはここから
ちょっと未来形が何柱でいたいんですけれども私はそういう行動するスタート世界超
防寒と名付けました
で
沢山の社会長国家をこれから作っていきたいと思いながら私は今さまざまな活動を
取り組んでいます
ではのためこういうことを考えるようになったかということについて今日は少し私の子
幼年期の頃から現在に至るここまで少し話させていただけたらと思います
はい属せない私はの幼年期
もうこんな動きな子どもで迷ういじめに遭い
学校に行っても何となく俗説どこにでも旦那がよくわからない
じゃあ常にモヤモヤしている8年を過ごしました
であの子逃げるチャンスありますが本当に恵まれた元に
私の家から
大学どうするこれからどうするっていう時にアメリカという所へ逃げる縁を作って
もらいました
エアのこれは自分とという非常に変わるチャンスてもらったんですけれども私は
やっぱりどうしてもこの日本というところにある現実から逃げるっていうチャンスを
活かし
アメリカで活動することに決めましたまずは留学です
で巡り巡って私は後の道に進むことになります
ね先ほどご紹介でありましたように私はの聴覚部に入ることになりました
部屋のまで日本語も英語もまたまだたどたどしい時でもあったことがありますそこも
自分というものを探す話は自分をどう表現していくのかということをこの3台の中で私
はすごく真ん中と思っていますそして1
私がいたことは5美術でこちらかというと違うはないと評価されない
ある意味違いということが非常に尊重する分野です
ちなみに今回好カード私も昔の写真を保持部って言ったら結婚でさんには
ねこれもあのいわゆる彫刻というきれい木を削って削りだすようなことっ
でこれもらか読みながら年度で作り上げ最後は拙攻で大きな塊を使うみたいな
あれ皆さんそうするそーかおやってきましたでその中でちょっとひとつ前のスライドに
待ったように私自分にしかできないアートってなんだろっていうものをすごく考えた
レッツされた時期でもあります
子供も作りましたね
でその後私はでラグビーに行こうと決めました
やっぱり実際流の私が本当に対する持っていた手紙の一説です
これは父からなったものです
まずないは卒業おめでと覚えておいてください
環境が人を育てますそれがない人はして悪阻でなくてはならないのです
あなたは今多分とても良い環境に入らずれる環境を与えられたチャンスを生かし勇気を
持って頑張ってください
本当に私はあのなんかこうおヤマ酵母や親ばかではなくてすごかった商品に対する愛情
がものすごく近い
いうのがあるんですがやっぱりこういう時時に頂いた親からの手紙っていうのはた仕事
一緒の宝です
でこのは大学に進むんですけれども大学いっていうところでいわゆる
ま1950年60年 they are というもう少しこかき的なこと私ができまし
た
今日は写真がないでは結構高いの作品がいいのでちょっとあの今日は嫁どうかなーと
思ってご写真じゃないんですけども
その中で5人
中問題だったりはてみにーずむだったり多様性って何だろうっていうことを考えさせ
られた状況でてきました
でその中で私は改めて日本人の女性としてアーティストとして何ができるんだろうって
いうことを考えました
そして同じように自分の子ばいるアジア知ったけれども
本当は日本人だしでもアメリカのコミュニティに入るとアジア系アメリカ人だしそう
思われるし
っていう読んだ後自分の中のアイデンティティを探すっていうことを大学院時代コウチ
ていました
私はその中で同時もともと作っていた高
ものを自分表現するっていうことからそうじゃない作品に出会う
そして新しい考え方と出会いはたくさんありました
って今回いくつか作品を紹介しながら私の考えると終わってきたが少し今日させて
ください
ただの皆さんアニマー新ピース
変を考えてもらう世界へを考えてごらん t 5秒子さんの作品です
私はこれを作品とした時にアートということはメッセージでもありというだけでもある
ということをしました
今回は launcher pro 3という作品なんですけれども10日間かけて
交流を住んでいくってさ
私がこれを見たときに
溶けると分かっているものそれを一つレス見たさでるっていうことにしかをかける
そんなの無意味なことですがアートなんだっていうことを知ることになります
ただその一見無意味に聞こえるかもしれませんがこの積み上げる工程で人と人との会話
だったりそこにいわゆるコミュニケーションというもの自体が
非常に大切だということを私は学びましたーーー
ってこれももしかしたら知っているかというかも知れませんか
えっ浄慶寺3-4分33秒9作品です
これはの楽曲ですで何かというとよぷっサージュ3秒間沈黙を味わおう核です
のが聞こえてきますよねこうこのかこと
彼は音楽です
で少しだけ高自分の心を進めたりをとおっしゃったとすることによって聞こえてくる声
だったり
たそうだったり気になったり私は細いとはねえつい強くだったりそういう社会もの見え
てくるっていうか私はしました
でアートは自分を映し出す鏡の予定役割だっていうことも私は思いました
ただ子自分の姿形を鏡連合ではなくってちょっと刷り込んでいく背景
例えば今日だったらこうやって皆さんいるそしてその外により兄弟がある
そしてもてく中盤あっ
怯えなものを想像するひとつの仕掛けっていうことが私はアートだと思っています
でその中で私にものすごく影響を与えたハッカ寒いよ説法しです
部屋の社会彫刻っていうことは実はここから借りてきている言葉でもあるんですけれど
も
彼の考え方
に関して私は非常に今の活動に影響を与えています
旨させていただきます
人間よる歌詞の全て全ての領域はたとえ者 by ももくという行為
それも意識的にはこれが検出と捉えるでこれは
言い換えれば
意識さえしていればどんなことにもアートなれる
逆に言うと20実はアートがあふれている
解釈にもなのかなって私はいつも思っています
でこの考え方次回
が今で社会彫刻という考え方なんですが私はこの考え方も今実際にあの現場でいたして
みたり
この考えが透過型もて大変ですけれども現在の県外だりに私なりに応用した時に一体
どういうことはどういう活動ができるかということを中心に置きながら今現在活動して
いるし
たいです
で
1詐欺整理をすると枚割りを飛ぶ皆さんアートっていうと特別な人は何か自分を表現し
て何か特別なものを作り上げるということかと思っている方もた方じゃないかなと思う
一方で私はそんな型競泳ギターとたくさん作品たちにあり最終的には私は今あぁいう
可能
以下が芸術界年自体の行動の触媒として考えたから
歩いが間違ったり学校だったり現場でいろんな風に足を発送しています
でえっと私なんだかなこの年は3塾かな
なんですけれどもこの数字皆さんの病害のあるように東日本大震災が起こりました
day
実際私もこのころからスポーツ日本に帰ろうかなと思い始めた時期だったんですね
でしばらくのいいがまだアメリカがあるの対応ではあったんですが
小さい冒険で最初に通ってるうちに改めて作り手としてアーティストとして単純にモノ
のはかなさ
あるもの壊れる可能性もある目の前のものはいつ何があるか分からない
食べて知らされた時間でまいりましたん
で同時に私にとって
こうやって色んなものをゼロベースでまた作り込んでいく人っていうものに改めて感動
し
カラーたちがやろうとしていることそれは何なんだろう
いろんなことを考えるきっかけそして一人一人の持っている価値価値観で何だろうって
いうことを真剣に考えた時に
まあそれこそもこの強い声の私は42歳になってるんですが
えっと改めて社会彫刻っていう言葉すらももう一度方
世の中に出すことによって一体これからも社会をどうなっていくんだろうというような
ながら実験的な活動でもあり真剣に私は者家族法をするっていう活動を走ってきてい
ます
ん
で繰り返しになりますが今度は日本で
明神女性として空き巣ととして1る社会彫刻家として何ができるか
私はそんなことを考えていました
で現在
えっと私は一つか行っている活動の中で福島県双葉郡富岡町ココアの非常にある原発
人口が影響を受けば足なんですが再開した後から私はコーディング学校作る活動をして
います
川湯20人の富士ん
そして東京やっぱり私は東京出身なんですけれども
意外と個性とかっていう知的な話はある中でやっぱり一人ひとりの考えにくい
だからこそ私は社会彫刻家というようなまあ生き方だったり
姿っていうものを育成するような市民大学を受けしていきます
阿部の偉大なお花が苦しいほどだけではないですし
域内者会場ぶっかけ嶋中なんて言われてもピンと来ないと思うんですよね
なんで私はそういう社会彫刻っていうところに来
結びつくようひょっとしてキー先や雇用妙な活動を企画をしています
でこれはプラスチックのラジオ体操という
夕朝5時から始まるんですけど錆びない集まるペットです
で単純にラジオ対処当てればいいですよね
でクラシックっていうのがいわゆる当たり前でもその2つが一緒になった時に色が
気づきがありますこういう気づき no yo 活動費アップもさせ
ています
そしてだけは私がここに男女にたず大きなビューにもなりました
越冬コミュニティ書くことキリア形成よという地形私は担当しているんですが
えっと開会あの毎年6名ほどのゲスを呼べるような構成になっていて
まあいわゆるゲストスピーカーという名の下
あの弱させて頂きますが
ああああああ
社外彫刻家という形を意識した上でお招きして
あの学生さんとでは次回だったりからたちの生き様っていうものを
からたちに感謝だともらうような機会をつくっています
でももすごいです
でちょっと改めてあのー私が遠いと生涯足かと思っているか
ここに書かさせていただいておりますいやーこれに関しては多分皆さんもそれぞれの中
で
こういう社会増効果行為者台帳効果っていうのがあると思うんですね
なんでこれは赤パパにも私は噛めるものです
おいしで読みます
世界に対する自分の中のさまざまな問題意識を迎えながら創造性や創造力を用いて
私生活や仕事に新たな価値を作り続け行動する1話の中では9さっきも人も感謝を言っ
たんですけどないやろし続け
キー僕が多い続けるって言うことは非常に私にとっては重要な
だと思っています
私はこんなことを考えて
あー三師会で毎日いろんな活動をしているんですけれども
それぞれの立場から小さなアクションオス付ける
そして価値観の自分を見た目た先の見える人にやさしい社会がを信じています私はこれ
は本当にかして神事でいて
えあのそれをこう氷山の一角ではないんですけれども
大きな目立つ活動するアクションを起こすということが10万ほどがなくて
一人一人がジャガイモ部ことですら
意識をしたときにいろんなものが想像されるっていう感覚を持つ人は私が増えれば
増えるほど人にもやさしくなれるした分間にも優しくなりだし
かけ3やさしくなれるして意味での意味を考えながら私は社会彫刻っていうことを使
こんなこと
を信じて活動しているあるです
南西私は社会上国家っていう人がたくさんいるようだと
作りたいと思うよっ
最後になりますがえっと皆さんでしたらどういう社会増効果
ありがとうございました
[拍手]